i'm here with jessica what do you do
here jessica
great question sal um i am my title here
is the chief of staff but i like to
think of it as a catch-all for any
position that we haven't hired full-time
for i pick up so it's a lot on the
business strategy and operations side of
the house and covers everything from you
know recruiting and
prepping our documentation for our board
meetings to going to costco and picking
up the toilet paper if we need it
when necessary some very high level
tasks to somewhat low level
but sometimes
has to get done and how did you end up
here where did you start your career
what did you think you were going to end
up being
yeah so i
i'm a native of california so i went
through the uc system uh went to uc san
diego and started studying electrical
engineering and you went on some type of
like super scholarship uh i was a jacobs
scholar while i was there it is a full
full merit scholarship for for irwin
jacobs yes dr erwin jacobs and his wife
joan very generous supporters of uc san
diego and started the scholarship
program in hopes of of attracting talent
on the caliber of the ivy leagues he had
he had been at mit before that and had
wanted to kind of create that culture
this was like a full ride
it was a full ride and how many students
get
got or got this at ucsd every year um so
the inaugural class and we were a class
of 10 a class of 10. class of 10. yes
probably not too easy to get
i was i figure i was just really really
lucky that my parents were very happy
and a lot less
they could go
by buy a car or something they were able
to retire a little bit
a little bit earlier yeah and and so you
you major in electrical engineering and
so you thought you were going to be
electrical engineer or i did so i did
all of my internships in electrical
engineering had worked at a number of
defense companies worked at qualcomm um
and and then i i ended up going to
stanford uh for a phd in electrical
engineering um and then my first quarter
actually got sidetracked when a friend
took me to a management consulting info
session
that was actually geared towards towards
engineers and i had no idea what this
field was and never heard of it um a few
people do
but they talked about you know you can
have all this impact you get to work
with you know amazing companies and
learn a lot and travel the world while
you're at it and i just thought what
could be a better education while
getting you know paid a little bit at
the same time staying in nice hotels and
exactly it's amazing how quickly you
become obsessed with like travel points
they're there and and how long did you
do that for i did that for three and a
half years following my master so i went
directly from stanford into mckinsey so
you were now in your like like early
twenties mid-twenties mid-twenties now
and what kind of work
how was how was mckinsey
what you expected or how is it different
than you expected and what kind of stuff
did you end up doing
so i ended up focusing on
kind of guess consultancy jargon of
operational and organizational
transformation well which looks at the
operational piece goes into
organizations oftentimes as technology
organizations in my case and looking at
how people did things and thinking of
ways they could do it more effectively
or more efficiently so worked with
engineers data centers executives and
the like
on the organizational side it was
actually looking more at how
company culture was and how you could
make that thrive in an organization and
think about development for people which
sounds eerily similar to some of what
you do here yes very eerily similar and
then a third piece of what i did at
mckinsey had this awesome stint in their
their internal learning group so
developing
the training of how how to make a
consultant a consultant and looking at
how to allow people to learn how to
problem solve and become better with
client relationships and interpersonal
skills so i i really love the learning
piece of it and then after and while
you're at mckenzie that's where you
first met shantanu who's our who's our
president yes we worked on several
projects together and so despite that
you still wanted to work with him
despite that for some reason rolls
rose-colored glasses
really good memories out of it um yeah
consulting was interesting it was a lot
of
long hours a lot of travel you know
people think it's glamorous when you're
traveling to other places oftentimes it
was like
typing up my powerpoint slides as i was
on the go it's probably a little bit of
both it was a little bit glamorous
the traveling was amazing i don't think
i ever would have had an opportunity and
you're normally and you were interfacing
at a very high level with a lot of these
organizations kind of the senior
executives best learning experience i
could have ever hoped for especially at
that age to be able to interface with
senior people at some major
organizations i could imagine would be
very absolutely it was it was an
incredible training ground and then
after that you
it was a three and a half years and then
you decided to leave for yeah so after
three and a half years the the lifestyle
was tough i found whenever i was at home
i was just kind of sleeping to make up
for the work week um and so i decided to
leave and i went to yahoo
given my kind of background in
transformations this was a company that
was in the midst of a huge one and i
thought i could help
so i went there um
also was a great actual learning ground
for me i was able to interface with
everybody from the engineers to
marketing finance legal and just learned
about the entire organization and how
things worked both on the search side of
the house as well as on the advertising
side of the house and and and you worked
with a
a whole where i guess what type of you
ended up at search
manager there yes so i ended up in
search as a senior project manager by
the time i left and so that sounded
pretty good so how did you end up here
yeah
so
now in hindsight is the worst decision
you've ever made best decision ever um
you can pay me five dollars after yes
i would have edited out any negative
remarks anyway i had um i had kept in
touch with shantanu and and so
he had told me over over time about how
he was interfacing with this guy named
cell who was making these youtube videos
and um
you know i just thought it was really
cool i checked out the site seen that we
had all these practice modules and some
analytics behind it and just thought
what was happening here was
awesome so i offered up my free time and
said hey i'd love to volunteer started
doing that
and then right around the time of the
ted talk things kind of got really crazy
for you guys
and i had been helping to try to find
actually a different role that you were
thinking of hiring at the time
and then when
kind of things got crazy shantanu said
hey actually
you might actually be a great yeah i
think we realized you were doing more in
your free time than we would have
expected from all of us it's like maybe
jessica's the right person for this and
then and then you've come and i mean
that was a it was 18 months ago but it
was like at an early stage i mean this
was how many people were we then yeah
when i joined i think i was employee
number six right after marcia she was
yeah
really early and now we're at
we're now
i believe we're in our early 30s early
30s early 30s
32 30 31 32 people and we have a bunch
of interns right yeah so it's we're like
we're like five times bigger than we
were it's incredible how much we've
grown yeah it is incredible uh wow and
and what what's your takeaway i mean how
how what's the experience been like and
and where do you think this is going to
go yeah so my experience has been
phenomenal i think beyond what i could
have i don't believe you i'm sure but
anyway
continue um but it's just been amazing i
think the people here are all just so
so thoughtful and so nice
and just awesome like everyone's
brilliant but just humble about it um
and so i just feel incredibly lucky to
be amongst this group of folks i think
as we've grown we've been able to main
the quirky fun culture of you know being
proactive and thinking epic and you know
shipping beats perfection some of our
values we've been really great at
keeping that going um you know as we
grow it's it's interesting i think
you know you once posed a question
around
where would we be like 500 years from
now
what would that ideal picture be like
and i think it'd be awesome if khan
academy still exists in 500 years and
that we're still completely free and
that
um
that we have all the content that
anybody could want to learn plug
directly into their brain yes by that
point hopefully it's just you know you
know plug in and you're done
but i think that would be amazing if if
we could leave
something for future generations to be
able to use and have a resource that
you know at this point in time seemed
unthinkable that it would be free and
that anybody could access that quality
of education
you're inspiring me jessica
oh
the feeling's mutual